if there is
anything that needs to be satirized and
remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample
trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just on
[Music]
big massive
[Music]
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once dumps
[Music]
what is going on here it's just beyond
parody
massive dumps cost of the election
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here what is going on
[Music]
all right let's get right into it
because we we don't have unlimited
time today and i have so many things to
go through with you because it's been a
while since the last stream
first and foremost just a quick
programming note we have
three new emotes from the standpoint
of twitch okay they are davidp11
bitcoin
that's weird i just typed it in in
twitch and nothing happened am i
am i supposed to type it in with a
specific format how do i designate that
it's a uh
man i don't even know what i'm doing
do i just type bitcoin
wow this is weird it's like my own i
don't even know how to use my own emotes
i just type bitcoin that doesn't work
either
can someone tell me how to use my own uh
emotes
oh a colon
david p11 bitcoin
that didn't work either is it just
bitcoin
what a mess capital b
jeez i can't even use it anyway so we've
got three new emotes they are bitcoin
chad man and beta i don't even know how
to freaking use these things it's so
pathetic
one colon is the colon at the beginning
or at the end
colon bitcoin bitcoin oh my god
yeah i don't know anyway other people
are using them so that's fine we have
three new emotes on twitch
um so that's fine all right
we we got that out of the way so three
new emotes
super chats radical liberal raphael
warnock says in louisiana vaccine
eligibility has opened to most people
excluding children i made a same-day
appointment
and just left with my first dose of
moderna very easy nice yeah
thanks to being vaccinated i actually am
going to be traveling next week during
our break
and i schwabbed today in both nostrils
and
i'm hoping for high marks on my tests so
that i can travel so i'll keep everybody
posted on schwabbing
um oh the beta emote is only
for uh tier one subscribers the beta
that's a big that's a big fyi the beta
emote is
only four subs thank you very much
the the the covet test was actually
difficult
um i studied all day yesterday to make
sure i'd get it all right
maddie says david you lied it is biden's
fault gas prices are rising he rolled
out an effective vaccine strategy that's
getting people back to work
which is causing demand to skyrocket
it's all his fault fair
fair that is true uh okay emotes we have
taken care of
i asked people last week to send me
information for when you get scam
telemarketer calls give me the numbers
and i'll call them
i just called an irs scam and told them
that my name was diego salabumbersmith
diego spelled d-i-e-g-j-o
can you imagine and uh they ended up
they ended up routing me to a real irs
number
apparently they realized that it was a
too obvious of a scam bait
so we might publish that during the
vacation
i have another one scheduled where i can
call a certain number to avoid legal
action
i might do that later maybe we'll even
do it do it on stream
no it's d-i-e-g-j it's even crazier
it's not d-i-e-j-o it i said it was
d-i-e-g-j-o
completely wacky name so we've got that
daraten says the ex-prime minister of
australia kevin rudd is running a
massive campaign against murdoch media
is also a cinephile and would be a
cynophile would be a great guest we will
look into that thank you
um okay got that out of the way
i am going to be ready to adjudicate the
croissant memes and we'll do it after
the biden event for people who want to
stick around we're going to adjudicate
the croissant memes later on today
i do want to say thank you via twitch to
artistic simplicity for the sub
astrolycos for the sub
master mcleavy for the sub mccool for
the sub
that's four astrolycos gifted five is
nine
breezy is ten regina
is eleven e moronic is twelve beaver
smart
is 13 nasty cues is 14.
so kicking us off really strongly at 14
today
light of the twin lamps as out of
curiosity does your family pronounce
your name as
david or david well if we're speaking
spanish it's the latter
um hope that makes sense unban
requests i do have one unban request
um
yeah the embed it's it's such a lame
unban request i don't even want to
adjudicate it because it's just too lame
i think i'm going to skip it latest
first oldest first there's like a ghost
unban request interestingly all right
we'll get rid of that
there is actually a producer pat emote
it is at a higher level of subscription
so you need to be at a higher level of
subscription
in order to make that happen um
let's see what else i've got here there
are really a lot of things
oh i had a very strong tweet yesterday
that some
actors and celebrities are reacting to
very strongly this one's got
about seven thousand retweets forty two
thousand likes
the uh star of season two of bosch
jerry ryan retweeted this one um
who else was it oh hold on no someone
else very well known retweeted this one
and now i forget
uh damn who was it it was a
female actress now i forget who it was
ah anyway that's lame i forgot about it
um i do have a funny thing from the
majority report
um sam cedar received his one million
subscriber plaque
and uh i'll just play this with no
expert this is pretty funny take a
listen the beijing thing
oh my gosh here it is
susan is one that david rubin likes to
like say me with me susan i might have
actually got him
i got how come my uh thing uh you know
denigrating uh people got demonetized
all right look at that it's gold it is
gold
what the is there a misspelling
you call it the minority report
presented to the david pakman show
uh oh what we're passing one million
subscribers the david pakman show
they got the wrong address and they
spelled pacman wrong
it's p-a-c-k on that isn't it oh no god
really they did smell it
wait you did that
[Laughter]
that's just the bag i can't believe it i
spelt backwards
all right there it is
[Laughter]
yeah i know i thought oh god you were
hyping this up for so long and you
didn't even spell it right
label maker
uh get access to our plaque but you did
that it's a ronald reagan trick and so
there it is whoa this is real gold
let's sell it
is sam having audio issues it sounds
like people are getting gated out in a
weird way
i don't know anybody else noticing that
your left hand believe me if this was
real gold i would have been like it did
never showed up but
sorry folks but yeah it's really the
thought that counts and i would have
sold this off this has been
all right so anyway he got his actual
thing and you know all right good
all right there is some uh but there's
an element of graffiti in oakland
that is pac-man it's my actual last name
it let me see is this spell this was
brought to my attention p-a-k-m-a-n
i don't know excuse me oh no i'm choking
and i'm missing my water uh i don't know
anything about the location of this
other than it's
it's oakland and it is uh it is my last
name
i haven't been to oakland for a while i
don't think it's any of our viewers that
did it
but uh that's kind of cool so we've got
that today
we also have this is very very cool
this is a what does it look weird like
that that's strange
this is the uh as some of you know i
once had this very freudian
slip where i referred to the world
famous
bonus show as the boner show
and one of our viewers made this i
believe they go by the name
phonak the second they made this this is
really really well done
okay i hope people are ready for this
get the kids out of the room
let's remind you that we have a
tremendous bonus bonus show
oh boy
[Music]
so you see the croissants flying
[Music]
oh boy let's and you see the coupon code
immoral 21 with soy milk
remind you that we have a tremendous
bonus bonus show
oh boy
[Music]
so really really explosive intro let's
just do it once now without me uh
interrupting we may have to adopt this
as the official
uh bonus show uh intro let's remind you
that we have a tremendous bonus bonus
show
oh boy
yep oh boy
let's remind you that we have a
tremendous bonus bonus show
oh
it's hard to believe this is my job
sometimes okay so we got that
i also ha actually no i'm gonna wait i'm
going to wait on i have another
announcement i'm going to wait on hold
on
uh oh let me just do this other thing
here's just another kind of like
pathetic anti-master type thing this
one's interesting
you can take oregano oil you can dilute
10 drops of oregano oil and drink that
over the course of the morning and do
that 10 days in a row
and your covert symptoms will be gone
oregano oil everybody
this is like an essential oils type
clown it looks like
now if you think that's i think that's
total [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
uh is this guy really that's this guy
can't really be with cnn right
honestly don't care what you think i
don't think you've done your research do
you understand how dunnon kruger works
i don't understand how anything you
refer to even makes
any sense brother what is that done in
kruger dunning krueger what is that
so like the stupidest people in the room
think they're the smartest
is your name dunning krueger like what
are you going to come out with next
occam's razor
the simplest explanation is that i'm an
idiot well
i mean that is interesting that's that
could be that's a little bit of a
self-ownage there
um really really weaponized ignorance as
you guys can all see now fortunately
vaccination is ramping up we have the
latest numbers here
we had massive dumps of vaccines over
the weekend
we had wait a second what day is this
saturday 3.1 million
sunday 3 million really really strong
yesterday 2 million okay
and we are likely within a day or two
going to breach the 2.5 million per day
uh dose number which is a really really
good number to have so i'm very excited
to see that
let's do some super chats um thoughts on
biden's assault rifle ban will
republicans use it in the midterms
democrats want to take your guns
well republicans have been saying that
anyway so what's the downside that
that's what they've been saying before
biden even talked about guns
i do want to say thank you to jacqueline
rusinski
jacqueline just signed up at
joinpackman.com
jacqueline thank you i want to invite
you yes well you or the yeah the you
yeah
uh to get a membership at joinpakman.com
we have an
unpublished coupon code which expires at
the stroke of midnight
friday um immoral 21
it's not illegal it's only immoral
immoral 21 and everybody who signs up at
jointpakman.com right now
i am going to say really great things
about you they're probably not even
going to be true
quite frankly but i'll still say them
all right also thanks to ranch fiend for
the twitch sub
party 1999 for the twitch sub short
brief
for the twitch sub that's three
three plus 15 is 18.
um i have a few oh this is kind of funny
so we have an open position at the show
i announced it last week we have 300
applicants
and so it's going to take a while to go
through it we're starting to uh sort of
uh
cull the wheat from the chaff so to
speak there were people who applied from
other countries we you know we need to
hire an american person for legal
simplicity
there were people who like you know
i don't know there were some people who
weren't good fits but 300
applicants here is something really
really funny
someone called in pretending to be troy
yorke to apply for the position
okay this is fake troy york applying for
work hey david pacman
your stupid deep communist fake
low iq dumb gay show from what i
understand has a
a job opening in it this is troy york
and
and i think i'm the perfect guy for the
job i mean
you're looking for for social media and
writing you know i'm good at this
david trump's twitter feed i i will
follow that all the time i would
ever go and take the disinformation all
right it's not that funny yep okay
delete so that's that and then here is
someone pretending to be a bad
applicant who didn't understand any of
the instructions for how to apply
hey david i'm a big fan of the show i
was a little curious
i'm actually interested in applying for
the position and i know you said
um voicemail was the only way to apply
of course i didn't say apply be a
voicemail the position opening that
you're hiring for right now i thought
that was a little weird at first but
uh you know i'm i'm content with it um
so i'm just gonna call and go over my cv
and uh we'll see where it goes from
there
okay so then they read their resume to
me
which i mean listen it's funny sort of
not really but there were a lot of
people who unfortunately
did not come close to even understanding
how to apply for the job
so i know that we're laughing and stuff
but let's just say
i'm thrilled we got 300 people who
figured out how to actually apply there
were some people who did not actually
figure out
how to apply and that was that was
pretty scary stuff
um christopher says getting my first
vaccine shot tomorrow getting an
appointment in many places if you want
one requires you to get on a waiting
list or pre-list yeah
last week my brother started calling
pharmacies
and on monday night he started and then
he called
uh like you know around closing time
monday tuesday
wednesday he got a pharmacy pharmacy to
say come on down we've got extra doses
so he was able to get his vaccine
basically my whole
family that's in the us now is
vaccinated which is
obviously great jd straightshot says
some people are saying trump's social
media work will be called locker room
talk or
toilet scrolling i was thinking
trumpogram
or twit trump maybe i don't know
i want to say thanks to brittany
blockmon
for signing up at joinpakman.com
brittany
you're unbelievable thank you so much
for signing up i really appreciate that
daniel asking if i will condemn the
graffiti artist in oakland who tagged my
last name on a bridge
i guess i mean i don't know graffiti
i'm not sure um
let's see what else we've got oh hold on
we've got breaking news from former
producer lewis
getting his first dose
well it's not even clear what he's
saying
saying uh got our first shots thursday
does that mean got an appointment this
coming thursday or he got his
vaccine last thursday kind of unclear
grammatical ambiguity from former
producer lewis that's tough
i do want to say thank you to tyler
jackson tyler just signed up at
joinpackman.com and is doing his part
um to do what i don't know
but certainly um doing his part
dave can you shout out my boys johnny o
and
arash in phoenix yes chakaseki
absolutely um oh
let's just do this is becoming
perfunctory do people want troy york
voicemails today
last stream after a string of no's
people voted yes
but the voicemails were so boring that
we just cut them
we just cut them i'm pasting the link in
um
twitch and youtube chat uh it is up to
the people
do you want detroit voicemails today we
want auto refresh of course
um it's funny people voted no for weeks
last week voted yes and then i couldn't
even get through them they were so
boring
the nose having it so far by about a
three to one margin that's a big that
would be
that would mark the biggest defeat for
troy york since the beginning
supposedly dead people voting here
going now to 70 30. freakadelic says
apropos of spam calls in case it hasn't
been considered register your number on
the ftc
site and spam calls cease after 24 hours
good
advice i appreciate that the nose
destroying
troy york right now three to one we have
never seen such a lopsided vote again if
you want to vote
i am going to paste the link to the poll
in twitch chat
a few times and in youtube chat a few
times we have 250 or so votes and by a
three to one margin the audience has
spoken
and they are saying no no no to troy
york this could be a green mirage we
could have late
entrants who are going to vote yes but
now with nearly 300 votes
still in that 70 30 range this may be
the end of
you know we should have a rule like a
super super majority
where if we ever get like maybe 85
15 no that's the end of troy york and we
never put it to a vote again
i think that that would be a reasonable
thing we'd have to figure out the
threshold maybe
85 15 maybe 90 10 but at a certain point
if it's so overwhelming um
you know that's that while we continue
counting i do want to mention something
funny
we got a um we have a new advertiser
that's going to be starting soon and
it's an
underwear line i'm not going to say
which one yet because it wouldn't be
appropriate until the campaign has
actually started
but these this is like it's pretty damn
aggressive
and they sent me some of these underwear
samples
and i one of them i saw and i was like
oh my god
it's like a thong uh and then it's that
it was actually a face mask with their
logo on it but i was so
rattled by the aggressive nature of
these undies
that when i didn't think i wasn't
thinking face mask i saw this thing and
i thought
there's no way in hell i'm wearing that
but it turned out it was just a face
mask with their logo
so we'll we'll have more news about that
as we get closer to launching the
campaign
i'm getting close to calling this guys
it's 70 30.
i don't know of any way that this is
going to be reversed the
the audience saying absolutely no to
troy york
barak rudd says i made a twitch account
and figured out how to link it to amazon
prime to use
the free subscription it worked take
that bezos
absolutely yeah thanks to super schluffy
as well as
sir fibble for signing up via twitch
putting us at 22.
i am officially calling the troy york
vote at 70 30.
troy york has been defeated and
brutally brutally so brutally brutally
so
no troy york voicemail so we will close
that out
kj asking about the job search i
mentioned this earlier we have 300 or so
applicants and we are
slowly starting to go through a process
james montalbano says overnight ballots
stand back and stand by yeah just troy
york brutally defeated
and many people glad about that thanks
also to
james lageness which i believe
i believe means the youth in french
james lageness signing up at
joinpackman.com and his new member
number 23
and if you're just joining us after joe
biden's
presentation today i will be
adjudicating the croissant
memes here is just one just to give you
guys an idea
sort of of what i'm and i've decided i'm
just gonna rank them and we'll find out
which which are the top ten
let's see if this loads here
here is one this is me with
what is this i guess cds
deepak attack this one may not win
that's okay but we have a bunch of good
ones i'll adjudicate these later
um definitely one of my favorites is
this argentina themed one
where i am addressed as a gaucho and
there is actually argentinian
gaucho art in the background i really
like this one
this one is in the running for sure okay
so we'll adjudicate those
after joe biden is done speaking
and then last thing as far as voicemails
go i did get one from the manic moderate
let me play that for you wow goodbye
from
lakeland florida hopefully be in
mexico soon right working on
all the paperwork yeah anyway
ford is moving those electric car
jobs to mexico ah
i thought the green new deal would
create
jobs we've not passed that we've not
passed the green new deal what's bob
talking about
oh that's right just like i said
mexico china
taiwan south korea
that's where the jobs would go
wire manufactured overseas
yep those solar panels
manufactured overseas wind turbines
they're all going to be manufactured
overseas
all right so the manic moderate bob from
florida
uh with an economic analysis today so
we've got
that thank you big thanks to luke
fitzgerald who just signed up at
joinpakman.com guys the coupon code is
working for the love of god
it's immoral 21 everybody's using it
luke used the coupon code james used the
coupon code
tyler used it brittany used it
jacqueline used it perfectly i've never
seen anyone use it as perfectly as
jacqueline so the coupon code i know
it's not what's up there
i'm giving you a better coupon code okay
it's immoral 21. that's two m's
jesus leon says rest in peace troy
voicemails maybe he'll get airtime on
fox
james montalbano says breaking troy york
has hired sydney powell to fight straw
poll results
and then um stephen is asking for a time
limit on polls in order to have a
consistent methodology
that seems fair that's something i would
consider
that that doesn't that doesn't seem like
a crazy crazy thing to say
uh all right very very good okay
new contest new contest alert
for those in the audience who are
good good with videos and memes later
today we'll be picking the 10 winners
for free memberships from the croissant
meme
here is the new meme format it is a
david pakman show
related edit of this infamous viral
video
now i don't know if in your conception
of this i'm the trump
or i'm the biden playing the drum okay
it's up to you guys but we this is the
new contest we're giving out 10
more memberships this this one's video
so we're going from visit from
pictures to video
[Laughter]
arguably one of the best of the trump
era
[Music]
maybe i'm the cat right i don't i could
be the cat i guess
sounds less funny but
[Laughter]
okay anyway so this is the new meme
format
all right i have 10 subscriptions to
give away
this one isn't even sponsored yet if
someone wants to get in touch
uh you know stacy sponsored the 10 we're
giving away later today
someone wants to get in touch and and do
uh get involved in sponsoring 10
otherwise we're going to give them away
i'm going to go into my pocket and give
away 10 memberships that's the one
deadline sunday deadline sunday all
right everybody
info davidpakman.com is the way to
submit it thank you to luke martin
who just signed up at joinpackman.com
using the coupon code immoral 21 luke's
new member number 25.
also want to say thanks to harry as well
as de sherminator
auntie inspo zita rocks
clay for signing up
oh and kieran live for signing up via
twitch and twitch prime
we do now have bonus emotes
for a twitch subs which is exciting
um all right so we did let me make sure
we did this
just a reminder new meme format
[Laughter]
all right get those in by sunday
uh okay i'll just play this as people
are just joining us new bonus show intro
let's remind you that we have a
tremendous bonus bonus show
oh boy
[Music]
oh boy let's remind you that we have a
tremendous bonus bonus show
oh boy
and as members of course you get daily
access to that so that's very exciting
we did this already we decided
absolutely no troy york voicemails to be
played today so we're caught up on a
number of different items here
and i think that that's a really really
great thing okay
so that is that oh people asking okay
for the memes the videos you get them to
me
info davidpakman.com i suggest don't
attach a file upload it yourself to
youtube and send me the youtube link
it's less likely it'll get stuck in spam
if you do that
very simple upload to youtube it's free
send us the link to info davidpakman.com
if you send it as an attachment it could
be brutally blocked at the server level
let me say thank you to someone who just
signed up for a membership
under the name coupon code worked thank
you
also thanks to brian allwood and
tom boulay who just signed up at
joinedpakman.com putting us at 33.
some people asking to hear
the scam call
um okay yeah all right i'll play a
little bit of it let me see here
let me see here uh how can i do this
we're not i i just i had a little free
time and i did a scam call earlier
let me see here if i can do this the
right way
okay let's listen
thanks for calling in let me skip ahead
here
oh here we go i don't know chris i got a
voicemail
saying i have overdue taxes that you may
be able to help me
i don't even really know what's going on
okay no problem do you know who left you
a message or a call
because i'll try and get you over there
i i have all i have is a tax id
oh may have it please yes it's seven
eight
four three seven
okay seven okay seven eight
four three seven okay so sir uh can i
have your first and last name
yes uh first name is diego d-i-e-g-j-o
and last name is sala salabumbersmith
i can spell it
can you spell it out for me sir yes it's
s z a
l a b u
m b e r
and then smith like you know smith
okay and their phone number let me
verify
it so i'm gonna skip over the phone
number because they don't have my number
but it might be a skype caller id it
might be someone's
i made up a tax id it might be someone's
number associated with the tax id i gave
okay so thank you for uh patiently
waiting on the line so according to the
file
it looks like the file the reason why
john
called your earlier because the ras
the ras has made some recent changes to
the first
uh fresh start program due to the uh
they've they're running a fresh short
coupon code themselves it sounds like a
coronavirus
so it looks like you are eligible for
some relief on your tax debt
did you get uh the information that was
sent in the email or in the mail
no i i just got a voicemail you're
saying that there were changes made
by the ras
yes sir wow and i didn't get anything
about i just got a voicemail from
john
no problem sir uh because i pull up the
file so i can probably go over the
information with you
so according to the notes on the file it
looks like
they are looking to provide me relief
through the ras
through a fresh chart program i guess
there were several things mailed to you
so there are new federal relief
programs for those experience
experiencing hardship
due to due to their tax debt
so right now taxpayers can be eligible
jew yes
that's the best moment right i mean
that's got to be the best
when he talks about jew i i mean
yeah i i don't know that there's
anything i need to even go back and
listen to that myself got a voicemail
from john
no problem sir because i pull up the
file so i can probably go over the
information with you
so according to the notes on the file it
looks like there were several things
mailed to you
so there are new federal relief programs
for those experience
experiencing hardship due to due to
their
tax debt so right now our peers can be
eligible
jew jesus
uh taxpayers can eligible to receive
forgiveness and
relief on a portion of their tax debt
based on a few factors now please
remember
these are relief programs so not
everyone qualifies
so however if you do qualify our
attorney will
able to review your file and possibly
help you with
uh to get the forgiveness or resolve
your tax debt
so let me go over the qualifying
questions with you before i send you to
the legal department okay please yes
okay so is your tax that uh above or
below ten thousand
thousand dollars absolutely
approximately uh sir how much do you owe
um eleventeen hundred
[Laughter]
eleven hundred eleventeen hundred yeah
okay so i i'm imagining he's writing
these numbers down and trying to figure
out how to do it
no okay so uh since these programs may
be based on your income
are you currently employed yes
okay so approximately how much
is your monthly income oh that's
that's tough i mean that's a very
private thing and i know
i don't know if you're based in the is
the ras based in the united states
uh yes sir but uh we are receiving calls
uh offshore oh you are
yes sir we are only working on the aria
uh irs
but we are receiving calls uh offshore
i'm just trying to are you with the irs
ras or the
s
i r s sir the irs
yes yes listen monthly income is tough i
mean what does my monthly income
need to be let's put it that way
[Laughter]
because so that uh we can know how uh
how
anyway so i this is the gist of it we'll
turn it into a clip for
for the vacation and i have some others
there's a legal
action one that i have that i might do
after
um i don't i mean it's something
different you know i i
i was having a good good time i know
guys i know i'm not as good as kit boga
okay i get it oh hold on a second we
have to do
i think we have to drop the ban hammer
here
oh jaby gatz just take care of it thanks
jaby yep
jaby gatz just dropped a ban banhammer
at exactly the right time
so i've got a couple others if you have
scammers and you want me to call them
you can email in with like the number
they give you to call
and you know if i get to them i'll get
to them and try to um
call call some of the scammers okay
freakadelic says via super chat let's do
some super chats you'll be surprised to
know that scott adams
the ever trump cheerleader dunks his
head and goofy grin in the toilet
after his sofa streams wow
phoenix jones says janet yellen believes
we will all be at full employment by the
end of 2021 60
of jobs lost were supposedly nullified
and not coming back magic or bs
well the question is how many new jobs
are created that are not old jobs that
were lost
uh i i'm taking a wait and see attitude
i
i just um we'll see we'll see i don't
know
let me say a huge thank you
um tell chat not the caller id that is
spoofed
oh boy i don't know what that means yeah
okay thanks to patricia logan for
signing up at joinedpakman.com
also thanks to victoria reed for signing
up at joinpacman.com you know there's
this incredible thing
where shows like the david pakman show
and tyt the majority report
we all have disproportionately male
audiences
whether the shows have female co-hosts
or hosts or not
we have disproportionately male
audiences and male members
but during live streams we get
disproportionately female
members what do people make of that
i don't i genuinely don't know what to
make of that
it's it's not something i've been able
to explain
during the streams the people signing up
or disproportionately
male names i should say traditionally
male names
um unclear what it what exactly it means
why aren't covet cases continuing to go
down yeah that's a good question
i have that here let's update the latest
numbers
so uh let's see here here is our case
trend and we had this big decline and
not only has it leveled
it's even ticked up just a hair over the
last few days
what i think is going on is that
we are starting to see younger people
unvaccinated people perceive that the
threat level is lower
even if they are not vaccinated and
they are going out and going wild and
they represent lots of the new cases
whereas when you look at deaths deaths
are continuing the decline
so what could be happening is that
there are declining deaths because more
at-risk people are getting vaccinated
and they're not going to die
and then you have young people going
around some of the variants
are more contagious although not
necessarily less deadly
and you're going to maybe see a lot of
them
represented in the new case numbers
that's my instinct but we can only wait
and see
what i can tell you is that this is not
over
if we continue to have 55 56 000 cases a
day
that's that's just what it is okay
um oh and someone's pointing out
you know if if deaths lag cases
then the deaths might just not have
flattened out i'm not sure about that
though because the flattening of cases
started february 20th
that's 33 days ago and
i you know we typically see a 21 day lag
we still over the last 12 days see the
death decline so that's a fair point
it's a totally fair point
but i think it would have started to
flatten already
um but i mean listen we're all kind of
guessing we're all working with
incomplete
information here so that's that's just
the best
guess and of course my specialty is not
epidemiology
um it's uh podiatry as many of you know
actually a pediatric podiatry
is my specialty okay
um do
unban requests i didn't think we had any
i'll take a look but i didn't think we
had any
let me see here
um oh okay we do have one hold on let me
get my gavel excuse me
i do have my gavel for adjudicating
unban requests
when people are banned on twitch they
have the opportunity to ask to be
unbanned
here's a user named mason labonte
who came in and said fu then
sent three links which were caught in
the spam filter
then said hi david then said fu
they were banned and then their unban
request is fu so we are going to go
ahead and adjudicate that
a permanent ban i am hereby denying the
unbanned request
there it is and then i have another one
here
juptoro who said
who built the cages joe who built the
cages
joe we vote trump no doubt joe built the
cages
based he's smart what about your son
hunter
it's because trump is anti-war they were
then
banned and then their unban
request is we do a little trolling
it's caller we do a little trolling
you know in theory i would unban them
if they just needed a timeout
but their unban request is so stupid
that i think i'm going to hereby
deny it and that is the decision
so that is it um that i'm just getting
i know some people are saying it's not
really ban worthy
i just it's just not a good vibe i don't
get a good vibe from it
um and i believe that that is it
although it's popping up yeah i know
that that one's borderline it's because
their unban request was just so annoying
that i just don't have any patience for
it
that's it that's all it is my friends
um you know it's sort of like if the
president does it it's not illegal
if i adjudicate it it's correct by
definition how about that
thank you very much everybody i
appreciate that okay
jacques roulette says some ladies use
male
screen names so they don't get dms
hitting on them
yeah but what i'm talking about sort of
like the opposite
uh so i don't know that that analysis
necessarily applies um
i'm getting some people wanting me to
start adjudicating memes now
yeah maybe we'll do it while we wait for
joe biden
let's see here so today we are going to
be giving out 10 memberships
i'll just go in order here's the way
we're going to do it
i'm going to rank these all right so let
me get a notepad out
and we will put it here i guess
let's see see how we can do this all
right good
and we'll just go in alphabetical order
and just the top ten that come up are
going to get
their uh they'll get the free
memberships okay
so this is the first one this is anthony
so this is the only one we have so far
all right
uh next meme this is from arn
this is uh irish croissants
i think this is better than the anthony
one so we'll put
arnie all right this could get difficult
we'll see
this is bosniaga
it looks like the full english breakfast
in one box
maybe fish and chips in the other trump
in the background
trump eating an ice cream behind me i
like this one i think this is the best
one so far
so this one is bosniaga
very nice this is brett bergner
this is jessie lee peterson in my
croissant box
with bernie in mittens in the back
it's not bad um i would probably put
this
i would probably put the second actually
so that's brett
very nice let's continue this is from
carlos
this for me is one of the top ones this
is argentinian david pakman
in a um uh a gaucho traditional gaucho
dress with argentinian gaucho art in the
background
this is going right to the top for me
this is carlos very very nice
this is christian what do we have here
looks like
frozen hamburgers with trump behind me
waiting for me to grill them up that's
really not bad actually
i would probably put christian
i'm thinking third christian is third
right now
this is close up channel
this is me near the trump cpac golden
statue
with watches we have a watch advertiser
on the show that's kind of clever
actually play a playoff of advertisers
on the show
i would probably rank this
i would put this below christian
close-up channel
remember the top ten get uh
a free membership we're still standing
by for joe biden let me see how people
are reacting to this
all right it's looking okay people
aren't angry with me so far
all right good let's continue this is
from dennis this
is me with my dad's dog with a dreidel
on its head
on my shirt that's a nice touch they've
added a third croissant box
kind of at the bottom here which is
funny
a bernie painting fouchy trump this is
nice this has some nice elements
i would put dennis probably i think
dennis is actually running third right
now
that's pretty good here is a
a different interpretation this is from
evan this
is a fake tucker headline beta pandemic
the left is spreading the true pandemic
a feminization that's pretty good this
one is really really good actually
i would probably put this i think i'm
putting this second
this is evan beautifully nicely done
evan i like this one uh
oh this is nicely done this is a
recreation
of the trump saint john's church
photo op with my media lunas and you can
see in the background the church service
board is announcing join pacman.com
and referencing this is a this is a a
bible verse that's very near and dear to
me
which is zuke's 3 16.
i actually think this is number one
right now
with no disrespect to carlos whatsoever
oh my god hold on everything just went
haywire
with no disrespect to carlos whatsoever
this is number one right now that is
jason
very very nicely done really really done
oh well done okay next the david pagman
show can you
imagine the medialuna's motherlode
this isn't bad actually i mean it's it's
i love the background being black and
white like artistically this may
actually be the best one
um yeah i i like this from jessica
a lot of talent here guys i am putting
this one
third there's jessica's very nicely done
here's me oh this is me in a kimono this
is from that caller who called in and
said david you in a little kimono
is that deer in the background and
what am i holding tortillas i don't even
understand this one
it's it's interesting i don't totally
get it
uh maybe this is probably i would put
john like
i'm probably putting john holy geez
everything's going haywire
i'm probably putting john right behind
the close-up channel
next is from laszlo boxes of delicious
promotional
treats arrived from fox's management
this afternoon
following today's hard negotiation about
my starting position
tucker carlson tacos and this one's not
so good
this one's not so good i think i'm
putting this probably
behind arnie laszlo
okay let's continue this is lauren
this is me with my granny smith apples
and my zooks
this is a nice reference to that caller
who said they want to see my
my zuks and then um
i said i'd be more likely to show my
grannies now can anybody tell what's on
the table in the background
i have no idea what that is see if i can
zoom it in
oh it's mail oh it's massive dumps of
ballots oh that's actually a pretty good
idea
i like that that's a good touch um based
on that
and the nice fruit work i think i'm
putting this
right ahead of bosniaga so there's
lauren
very nice clever
uh let's zoom out there we go now this
is a different lauren
sourdough senate i have pictures of
senators
in the boxes and this is not so good
this is not so good i would probably put
this below bert so this is
lauren chris that's a different lauren
all right here's maria this is me with
ballots
okay yeah the ballot id is interesting i
think the other one was better executed
where they're in boxes on my
on my table so i would probably put this
below close up that's maria
just want to make sure we're not missing
the biden event no we're not okay good
it's kind of meh yeah i get it i get it
here is from nick this is money bag
deepak
i've got the bitcoin uh necklace
it's me in the mona lisa my million
subscriber
gold plaque on the wall and you can see
trump playing golf
out the back window this is nicely done
this has some interesting elements
uh so i would probably put nick
i think i'm putting nick fifth right now
call me crazy i'm putting nick fifth
here's phil phil has me wearing a shirt
that says i love massive dumps
with a magga hat on the table trump art
and then ballots the idea
is about a six and a half
the execution is like a four and a half
i think i would say
so i'd put it kind of right in the
middle
um maybe bef after close-up channel
i think maria's was actually better so
i'm putting phil there
with total peace and love reuben
has i've got a bo i have boxes full of
bernie and mittens
and then trump's in the back window and
this is this is legitimately not that
creative
i would probably put this here that's
ruben
next is tony nowak my face instead has
biden and then it looks like melania and
trump's decapitated heads
i don't think so i don't think so i
don't think this is so good
i think this is pretty low i'm putting
that right behind laszlo
here is tyler this is a fake instagram
post
hey guys i want to thank all the legal
votes for our decision to permanently
continue the troy york voicemails
i'm wearing the trump rioter
hat this is okay i mean the effort's not
bad here
i'm thinking probably somewhere around
here i'll put tyler there
we're getting to the end this is wake up
style
pick your almost illegal treat i have
one box of media lunas and another
another one of coupon codes better 21.
okay um
it's in the same area i'm thinking here
wake up style is here
that may have been the last one that is
it
so ladies and gentlemen we have a winner
the two winners uh or the ten winners
are
jason carlos jessica evan
nick and lauren bosniaga and dennis
christian and close up channel that is
it
one two three four five six seven eight
nine and ten as a reminder the winner
is jason's perfectly executed photo op
me with my croissants at st john's
parish house
praying at the altar of zuke's 3 16
really really nice job and second place
is carlos with the depiction of me back
with my argentinian roots not only
holding argentinian
croissants but also uh in gaucho where
but congratulations to everybody who
participated
let me just email myself the 10 winners
and you have all gotten a free david
pakman show
membership that's tremendous isn't that
great memberships
nice community event okay so there's
that
and as a reminder as a reminder
hold on where was this uh trump biden we
have a new meme contest
10 more opportunities to get
free david pakman show memberships but
this is a video contest
based on this
okay so if you want to participate in
this one again it should be david pakman
show related
maybe i'm biden maybe i'm trump maybe
i'm the cat maybe i'm in the background
but this is the new one deadline is
sunday so you have five
full days
[Music]
okay all right so we got it that is the
next one info at davidpakman.com some
people already saying that's too
difficult
uh let's go to this joe biden event
important announcement breaking first
let me
say that my heart and our prayers
go out to all the individuals and
families in colorado right
regarding the tragic shooting but it is
indeed an
honor mr president to have you
here in the heart of my district the
james
it's part of your help is here tour with
my colleagues
congresswoman marcy captor congressman
tim ryan and what a privilege former
guest on the show
here at the ohio state university in the
james
with madam president dr christina
johnson
yes a scientist with chancellor
howe paws with dr farr
dr andy thomas dr wong and so
many more of my ohio state colleagues
and friends especially as we celebrate
the anniversary
of the 11th anniversary of the
affordable care act
being signed 11 years ago
on this very day since then a lot has
changed mr president
more than 20 million americans are newly
insured
and countless more can now find
affordable high quality
health care plans that best meets their
needs
without going broke right i remember 11
years ago
i was here as a senior vice president
at the ohio state universities when
students found out that they could stay
on their parents
insurance until they were 26 years old
seeing the relief on their faces and
hearing
in their voices that they wouldn't have
to be
forced to go without health care
coverage
not to mention the fact that
pre-existing conditions
like cancer or just being a woman
would no longer prevent more than 130
million
americans from getting treatment or
being kicked off their health insurance
mr president i am excited to serve
with you and as you mentioned on that
historic day in 2010
the affordable care act is a big deal
and it still is and the same can be said
about the american rescue plan it is
all about meeting the magnitude of the
moment of my constituents
lives are on the line and this is a
pocket get
people back to work return children and
our teachers
to the safety of the classroom improve
vaccine distribution and yes
strengthen our economy i want to thank
you mr president and vice president
harris
for pledging direct relief to people
and small businesses that need it the
most
and this landmark life-changing piece of
legislation
makes good on that promise together with
you
your administration my colleagues and my
osu family of doctors
and scientists we can defeat covet 19
and make promise on the pressing issues
facing
our country including something that i
know is extremely personal to you mr
president
defeating cancer as evidenced by your
cancer
moonshot initiative so let's go defeat
covet 19
so we can end cancer as we know it
and continue to build back
better now it is my pleasure
to yield to tameka harrison a manager
of case management and social work right
here at the ohio state university
wexner medical center's east hospital
to introduce the 46th president
of the united states mr joe biden
i assume that's a reference to leslie
wexner the victorious secret guy i'm
guessing he donates to hospitals right
[Applause]
oh strong sanitation i'll take that as
an opportunity
to thank kevin cantor as well as jordan
purvis
and mason dockery for signing up at
joinpackman.com thanks guys
good afternoon my name is tamika
harrison
and i am the manager of the case
management and social work department
at the ohio state wexner medical
center's east hospital
i'm excited to share reflections
regarding
where we've been where we are today
and the excitement as to what the future
of
of the american rescue plan act will
bring to the osu health system
and its patients as we look to the
anniversary of the affordable care act
i recall when it was implemented we saw
many
excuse me we saw and many times assisted
patients and families with getting
enrolled in health care plans
including medicaid managed care plans
thereby providing them with access to
the affordable health care
that they so deserved and many
desperately needed
we are now at a point to where patients
and families do not
need to use the emergency department as
primary entry into our health care
system
the aca has afforded them access to
obtain primary care provider coverage
or linkage to an accountable care
organization
thus allowing for the provision of
increased continuity of
care this as we all know
leads to better health outcomes for
patients and their families
because patients have had increased
opportunity and more affordable options
for access to care we have used less
patient and family emergency resources
for services
both inpatient and outpatient this
includes services such as dme
which are walkers and wheelchairs things
of that nature access to transportation
and post acute care services such as
home iv
infusion and skilled nursing visits more
importantly though
it allows our patients better access to
more specialized
services like that which is provided
within the radiation oncology department
at the james cancer hospital and so law
research institute
i am looking forward to the lower
premiums
and the expanded opportunities for cobra
afforded by the new american rescue
plant act
of 2021. that's true this act will help
patients
like one i vividly recall a patient who
had a job but just couldn't afford the
coverage
that was afforded to them at the time
this patient came in with an infection
and then needed long-term iv antibiotics
in the past this patient would have had
to stay in the hospital
to receive those services today
with access for better coverage these
services can be covered
in a home setting i am truly grateful
for the difference the aca and now the
american rescue plan
are making in our patients lives so
please
join me in welcoming to the podium
president joseph
r biden
thanks to kyle ruth for the website
membership appreciate
it while the sanitation happens also
thanks to symptomatica and margot
cabot new members number 40 and 41 today
coming in strongly via twitch
tamika thank you very much i guess i'm
supposed to keep this on correct
yep keeping it on
good afternoon almost getting an evening
before i imagine joe biden doing what
the policy is of the place where he's
speaking
isn't that strange today at the white
house
i address the mass shooting in boulder
colorado
while the investigation is ongoing and i
spent time in the telephone with the
attorney general as well as the head of
the fbi
this investigation is still ongoing
my heart goes out to the families of the
victims and the survivors
i want to i want to commend the heroic
actions of officer
eric talley the father of seven children
who left for work yesterday morning
assuming he'd be able to go home
and for the ultimate sacrifice he made
for others
horror now let me turn to why i came
today
to talk about initially the american
rescue plan and the progress we're
making on tackling covet
to make a thank you for sharing your
stories and what you're doing my
daughter is also
some people's lives and all you do to
connect
folks here in ohio with the coverage and
care they need
i want to thank joyce congresswoman for
sticking with me during the day and
marcy my old friend
good to see you marcy thanks for being
here and tim ryan always
kid with tim if you're i've got to be in
a foxhole he's the guy i want to be with
he always keeps his word does exactly
what he says he's going to do
and it's great seeing you tim my best to
the family
madam president thanks for having uh
served in the obama biden administration
and you're doing an
incredible job here and all the docs
that are here that i got a chance to
meet with today
thank you you are you're an incredible
group of individuals
i also want to thank sherrod brown who
wanted to be here today but he had to be
in washington to cast
important votes in the united states
senate look i want everybody to be aware
that there are
three key parts of the american rescue
plan all my colleagues supported here
first we're going to more rapidly
acquire so obviously
because biden's wearing the mask and the
mask is making his
breath audible the right is going to say
the mask is there
to cover some terrible illness that's
causing him to breathe like this that'll
be
the conspiracy after this able to
organize and help increase the number of
doses in a much shorter time
so by the end of may we're going to have
on hand roughly 600 million doses enough
for every american
and the american rescue plan is also
going to provide funding
for more vaccination vaccination sites
vaccinators
and the paraphernalia needed to put that
vaccine in one's arm
in addition there is a second important
piece of that plan
it's focused on dealing with the
economic deprivation so many americans
have become subject to a consequence of
this virus through no fault of their own
millions have lost their jobs and are
still out of work around 11 million
children
in america are going hungry through no
fall of their own but as a result of the
pandemic and the economic crisis
millions of americans are not able to
maintain their mortgage payments or
rental payments
and have found themselves on the verge
of being evicted of having their homes
repossessed
we stepped in and we prevented that from
happening with the american rescue plan
hundreds of thousands of businesses are
now
not going to go under but they're going
to have an idea an opportunity to reopen
and have the financial assistance to be
able to do it the right way and safely
schools clothed and children losing up
to a year
more in learning capacity you're ahead
of the skates here in ohio but across
the nation
it's the help was badly needed and we've
now provided the funding for that
because of isolation and violence
against women is up abuse of children is
up in the need
for mental health problems to deal with
a mental health problem the consequence
of them is up as a consequence
of covet and in addition to that
suicides are
the second uh so second the american
rescue plan brings relief
to a population that's badly hurting and
one more element of response
is that first and foremost is a
commitment to get
americans fourteen hundred dollars
checked per person including per child
so a firefighter and a school teacher
making 120
000 combined with two kids are gonna get
a direct payment of five
thousand six hundred dollars in
cash if they already have a an account
online with the irs which many do
by tomorrow we will have distributed 100
million of those
checks just since the legislation passed
we're on the verge of doing that as of
tomorrow but for someone who doesn't
have direct deposit
they're getting a check in the mail for
all that so we expand the child
we also expanded the child care tax
credit
right now if you file your federal
income tax
you get to a two thousand dollar
deduction for every child you have
but if you're making the minimum wage
you don't know enough to file for
federal taxes but because of the
american rescue plan
if you have two children for example
under the age of six
you're gonna get a check for three
thousand six hundred dollars
if you have if you're a a child and so
if you have two children seven thousand
two hundred dollars and be paid on a
monthly basis
this is going to be life changing it's
estimated this will do more to end child
poverty in america than anything we've
ever done
there's also the earned income tax
credit if you're over the age of 19
and not a full-time student and you're a
childless worker
now you will get a check for one
thousand five hundred dollars if you
file
small businesses not only will be able
to borrow the money to keep businesses
afloat
but get loan forgiveness and improving
your business to get us back in the game
and by the way all of this
economists left right and center argue
and acknowledge will create seven
million more jobs and
increase economic growth increase
economic growth
there's so much more but help is here
but i'm here in this great hospital to
talk about a third way to help
and that's for your health third type
health and that's healthcare
i just concluded a tour of the radiation
oncology department here at the james
cancer center which expanded
thanks to a 100 million dollar grant the
affordable care act
that sherrod brown was instrumental in
making happen
that's in addition to the research
funding ohio state received under the bo
biden cancer moonshot
because of our investments this
department has gone from being able to
treat
60 to 70 patients a day to nearly 300 a
day
this place is a source of hope i've said
that i
wanted when i when i ran i said i wanted
to be the president who would
preside over the end of cancer as we
know it
when we see this this is not super high
energy i don't think the mask is helping
in particular
it's within our reach we're all benefit
from the breakthroughs pioneered by the
defense department for example research
agency called darpa
which helped bring us everything from
the internet to gps
well i'm going to be proposing to my
friends in congress that we launched
a similar operation at the department of
at
at the department of health a new effort
called rph to deliver health
breakthroughs they'll find cures for
cancer and other diseases
by investing billions of them but those
vaccine numbers are looking pretty good
to do drug companies not have not the
capacity
and i know we can do this i know we can
find great breakthroughs
america does big things 11 years ago
today
president obama signed into law the
affordable care act
historic achievement it would not have
been possible much for the vision and
determination of one of the most
successful presidents
in recent american history barack obama
i might note parenthetically when i got
in the automobile to go to the
to the uh to hhs he was laughing
i didn't know what he was laughing about
he said did you hear they picked up what
you said
on the mic all i could think was thank
god my mother wasn't around
you hear it but look on this anniversary
you should remember just how close we
have come
to losing that act so what we fought so
hard for
and we have a duty not just to protect
it but to make it better
and keep becoming a nation where health
care
is a right for all not a privilege for a
few
when i ran for prom for president i
promised i would build on the foundation
of the affordable care act
and just 50 days into my administration
we've delivered on that promise with the
american rescue plan
it does that by making health care more
affordable
it means better coverage and lower
premiums for millions of americans
if you're enrolled in obamacare you're
going to save an average of fifty
dollars a month
six hundred dollars a year by the
reduction in payments
for a family of four earning ninety
thousand dollars a year that could save
you
two hundred dollars a month in savings
for a sixty year old couple here in ohio
earning seventy five thousand dollars
per year
you could save them about one thousand
dollars
per month and to maintain the cell same
health care
that's twelve thousand dollars a year in
your pocket that you didn't have before
because the american rescue plan if you
lost health care because you lost your
job or your hours were cut
we pay your contribution and your
employer's contribution on a so-called
cobra that's what your
employer-based health insurance was and
so
since if they've gone out of business or
you're no longer there because you had
to be laid off
you can stay covered for up to six
months until you get back on your feet
because we'll the federal government
will cover both ends of that cobra
payment
for millions who are out of work and
have no coverage
thanks to this law there's an obamacare
plan
that most folks can get with zero dollar
premiums co-pays will still be there but
zero dollar
premiums four out of five americans
shopping
on the obamacare marketplace can get
quality health care with a premium of
ten dollars a month or less let me say
that again
four out of five americans who shop for
a plan will find
one for 10 or less per month
it's especially important in communities
that historically have gone without
insurance
at higher rates very few communities
that have always faced health
disparities brown black and asian native
american communities
have borne the brunt of the covet crisis
we're also making it easier easier to
sign up for obamacare
we've opened healthcare.gov for special
enrollments on february the 15th
in the first two weeks alone more than
200 000
americans gained coverage today i'm
pleased to announce we've extended that
period to run through
august the 15th just go to
healthcare.gov or call the national
hotline
1-800-318-2596
did he say august of 15 or august 15th i
think i misunderstood that maybe
a few clicks in a short conversation
that's all it takes to start seeing
these benefits increase coverage and
lower premiums i'll close with this
with the american rescue plan and
affordable care act millions of families
will be able to sleep a little more
soundly
at night because they don't have to
worry about losing everything if they
get sick
i like many of you grew up in a middle
class i guess technically
lower middle class household based on
income
we lived in a three-bedroom split level
home with four kids and our grandpa
living with us
and the paper the walls are paper thin i
can imagine hearing my dad
rolling back and forth i could tell
there's something wrong i remember
asking my mom
next morning what's the matter with dad
she said honey he's just worried we just
lost our health insurance no longer has
this coverage
people lying in bed wondering my god
what happens
what happens if in fact i get sick
what happens if i turn she has breast
cancer or i end up with a heart
condition
what happens and god forbid you're
sitting in the edge of a hospital bed
with someone you love like i did with my
son beau as he was dying
and all you have to think about is all
they have to think about
is getting better not what happens if an
insurance company could come in like
they did before obamacare and say sorry
you've outrun your coverage i should sit
there and think my god what would happen
what would i do that's the difference
we're going to keep building until every
american has that peace of mind
and to show that our government can
fulfill its most essential purpose
to care for and protect the american
people
when we work together we can do big
things
important things necessary things
we saw 11 years ago with the affordable
care act
we saw it 11 days ago when we marked the
signing of the american rescue plan
but we're not done yet last week
we met my goal that i announced of
administering 100 million shots in my
first 100 days
in office at the time the press said
that's awfully audacious
now that we've done it in 58 days we're
saying boy he sure set the bar off a low
well this week we're announcing a new
goal to get more people vaccinated
but we need all the americans to keep
washing their hands
big announcements staying socially
distant and wearing the mask
when you're in public as recommended by
the cdc
and get vaccinated when it's your turn
it's a patriotic responsibility you have
now is not the time to let down our
guard
if we all do our part after a long dark
year
we can show once again that we are the
united states of america
that there's nothing we have cannot do
if we do it together
we're going to beat this pandemic
because of the great docks up this
staircase here we're going to beat
cancer as we know it as well
we're going to make sure once and for
all that healthcare is a right not a
privilege
in this nation i want to say to
again the docs who spent the day with me
all the incredible work you're doing i
told them that
when my son contracted stage four
glioblastoma and coming home from iraq
when he was in iraq that i had the
opportunity the president
asked me to do what they called a cancer
moonshot
i put together an organization made up
of seven nobel laureates
as well as another 30 docs in cancer
field
and i was able to go and visit every
major cancer facility in the world
save one and we have some of the finest
minds in the world and they're right
here
right here at ohio state ohio state
right here in ohio right here in the
united states of america
and they break their necks every single
day for us
we owe them i want to thank you all
may god bless you may god bless us all
and may god protect our troops thank you
thank you for the hospital
so there's president joe biden
delivering remarks he will give his
first four formal full
press briefing of the presidency on
thursday and i will be here for it that
will be the last
stream on my channel
for the vacation week and then we'll be
back in early april
uh before we we wrap i do uh uh
nathan called my att nathaniel called my
attention to a really powerful story
of de-radicalization this is on the
subreddit
listen to this inspirational story how
david pulled me out of the alt-right
this is really something
sorry if some of you feel that i don't
belong on here i know i've done a lot of
bad in the political discourse but i
wanted to thank david for pulling me out
of the depths of magaland
i grew up in a republican household but
never thought too much about politics
for myself
until i started listening to joe rogan a
few years ago
that's when i fell into the pipeline
that made me believe some crazy
disgusting things eventually i started
to seek and interpret the codes from
q and if i didn't stumble on one of
david's streams
i might be behind bars today for
storming the capital
in late october last year i came home
from work
and was looking for another liberal
stream to spam with anti-semitic
messages
david's came up and what he said changed
my life forever
he went on a speech about how most
peanut butters on the shelves of grocery
stores
have no business calling themselves
anything but peanut butter spread
because of all of the other ingredients
beside peanuts and salt on the
nutritional label
i was shocked i ran straight into my
kitchen and saw
that what david said was right when i
read the label on the peanut butter
in my pantry i was too irate to admit it
but a liberal was right about something
and my world view was shaken to its core
not long after i started to wonder
whether or not what trump was saying and
promising about making america great
was being mislabeled just like my peanut
butter turns out that trump was only
making america worse with his policies
that only benefited the rich and himself
i felt betrayed
but there was only one thing left to do
on november 3rd
i grabbed my maga hat and jar of peanut
butter spread
i went to my polling place and threw
them both in the trash
before voting for joe biden and every
other
democrat on my ballot what
a life-changing earth-shaking story
of de-radicalization my friends
absolutely inspirational
motivational uh
really truly stunning stuff and uh for
more power
powerful stories like that join the
subreddit we're at 29
000 viewers on the subreddit let's get
to 30 000.
davidpakman.com if
this is new copy pasta this is this
people are asking is that fake yeah it's
fake in a sense but it's not like a
known copy pasta it's it's specific to
the david pakman show
all right remember new meme contest
this is the new meme format
okay it's a video meme format submit
them to me
info davidpakman.com by
sunday by sunday all right
on twitch we are going to raid
oh there's no one i really follow right
now that we should raid
let's raid the boats as sisters that's
all i'm seeing maybe we'll get a mention
from them
all right so everybody thanks for
following and watching and all of this
stuff
and on thursday we'll have the joe biden
press briefing
and it's all going to be crazy i
appreciate you joining me we'll see you
tomorrow then thursday
you